hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin
näher zusammen mit minecraft zeigen
minecraft in minecraft das dass ich es
machen und damit ich habe mir aber
einfach gedacht heute freitag ist und ii
die serie so toll findet findet ihr doch
hoffentlich oder zeige ich euch halt
heute mal ausnahmsweise und zieht
alleine ich wäre es ja noch nicht mal
fährt
jetzt fängt das andere da vorne an das
ist nicht wahr dass hat sich genau
gerade gedreht und dann auf einmal hört
auf und schaut mich an die bescheuert
ich dachte nur den er hätte probleme mit
pferden aber bei mir ist es irgendwie
mittlerweile auch zu der fall
ich habe heute sogar zwei schied
vorbereitet und der erste sieg ist mein
gott ach ich habe die samen der hand da
ich jetzt schon dieses hühnchen an mir
dran kletten habe hole ich den jetzt
einfach mal hier so einen
paarungspartner hierhin direkt und jetzt
könnt ihr zusammen
wieso macht er denn keine liebe
miteinander
ich habe heute 26 vorbereitet weil die
beide ein bisschen kleiner sind der
erste zieht ist der hier - 1 48 03 51
in ihre kleine familie
sind sie nicht knuffig und hier vorne
haben wir das einzige häuschen was es zu
gehen
wo ist denn der will ja da drin hin
keine
da ist auch der wille da hier vom
häuschen das ist nämlich die einzige
person die in diesem village ihr
wirklich lebt wenn man es wirklich
village nennen kann wir jetzt aus einem
gebäude hier besteht und dazu haben wir
halt noch dieses feld hier unten und das
ist quasi einfach einzieht wenn ihnen im
kumpels abgebildet
hh
das ganze ist quasi schon zieht nummer
eins da der quasi einfach nur so kurz
ist allerdings sicherlich einfach mal
zeigen wollte was wirklich das kleinste
dorf in minecraft ist habe ich halt wie
am anfang schon erwähnt ein
warum habe ich immer so dumme tiere in
meiner welt bevor wir allerdings jetzt
mit dem zweiten sieht weitermachen
kalenderteil heute ist der 18
dezember deswegen haben wir mal das
achtzehnte türchen raus wo wir eine
komplette landschaft wurde gerade
zerstört ich hätte ja echt nie gedacht
dass ich irgend einer für diesen scheiß
kann länder interessiert aber ich habe
es wirklich zwei mal vergessen dass zu
zeigen und da kam wirklich leute in den
kommentaren deswegen hier
das war heute bei der 18 drin das ist
ein kleid das hänge ich mit einem
kleiderbügel und dann machen wir auch
schon direkt weiter mit dem zweiten
sieht da ich jetzt ein zweites zieht
auch keinen riesigen sieht nehmen wollte
weil wir quasi schon für den ersten sieg
ein bisschen länger gebraucht haben habe
ich einfach einen zweifel zieht genommen
das ist die komplette insel der sieht
für diese insel lautet 9 381 92 20
hört sich an wie eine telefonnummer auf
dieser insel haben wir ein wenig
zuckerrohr wir haben relativ viele bäume
im vergleich dazu dass es wirklich ein
survival sieht es und wir haben hier
relativ viel sand erde und das einzige
wovon wir überleben können samen bzw
brot weit und breit ringsumher finden
wir sonst nichts anderes als was aussah
wenn ihr nämlich mal in den südosten
schaut seht ihr schon ein wenig unter
wasser wieder so ein komisches ich
sollte man so eine porsche nutzen dann
haben wir unter wasser wieder so nennt
portal wo wir quasi direkt ins ende
teleportiert werden können das haben wir
auch schon der letzten folge entdeckt
dass verlinke ich euch mal hier
da findet ihr die letzte folge ceo da
könnt ihr auf jeden fall mal drauf
klicken jetzt sofort ja kommt schaut sie
euch an oder schaut euch jetzt das video
zu ende keine ahnung und das hier sieht
quasi genau so aus also ich kann auch
hier wieder ein loch einschlagen dann
kommt er quasi wasser rein das ist
allerdings erst mal relativ egal weil
er ist gestorben hier haben wir halt das
portal das ist hier wieder direkt und
ich wollte ihn eigentlich nur
vorstellbar da oben sonst bauen dann
habe ich auf einmal gemerkt als sie mit
dem internet angeschaut habt ihr auch
luca dauern ist übrigens auch noch so
ein ding
alles klar das ist quasi für heute steht
nummer zwei also eine art zu beziehen
weil ich dachte der erstes jetzt kein
zweifel zieht aber es ist halt quasi für
den dorfbewohner so eine art survival
weil er auf sich allein gestellt ist und
ich kann auch sehr gut mit dem schielen
ich wollte mich am film supertalent
bewerben ich glaub ich kann sogar so
switchen
das tut fucking wer alter da wir hiermit
wieder die komplette messlatte der
dummheit hoch gelegt haben und meine
augen unglaublich weh tun würde ich
sagen wenn ihr geiles ins camp zeigt mit
einer
wie wollt ihr es mit einer bewertung
zeigen luca wenn ihr noch eine sieht
vorstellung haben wollt nächste woche
oder so dann zeigt mir mit einer
bewertung und wenn ihr cooles kennt dann
schreibt die gern mal die kommentare
dann werden sie will nächsten mal wieder
dabei wenn wir beide werden ihr euch die
das nächste mal ausschalten